hell hath no fury like bella thorne
scorned I wish that didn't dig as deep
as it did
yes Bella finally weighed in on those
surprise pics of Jake Paul having lunch
with his ex Erica castel less than one
month after he said I do to Bella's
ex-girlfriend Tana mojo so a fan wrote
to Bella quote jake has used all the
cloud he can from Tana mojo so now he's
over it and moving on to newer scandals
that will bring him clout bella thorne
help us get hot girls summer Tana back
the 21 year old reposted the tweet
adding while her family is going through
some [ __ ] not a good look Jake are you
serious I know this is crazy that fellas
referring to a family emergency that
kept Ana from joining Jake on their
European honeymoon followed by the
unexpected death of her grandmother yeah
I gotta agree with Bella on this not a
good look Jake Bella was in an open
relationship with rapper mod son and
tana for nearly a year but in February
she announced she was no longer seeing
Tana when Bella heard the news that Tana
got engaged so quickly after their
breakup she posted these tearful pics
with the caption when your ex gets
engaged
I never fade but Bella isn't the only
one who took to social media to call out
Jake for going on a date with his ex
Tanna did to changing the lyrics to
Ariana Grande's thank you next even
actually got married and for Jake I'm so
thankful when he goes out to lunch with
his ex and I find out on Twitter
Jake and Tana said I do in Las Vegas on
July 28th this is my wife many were
skeptical of their engagement including
Jake's own brother Logan who believed
the union was quote fake where it's like
he loves his brother and you know like
if it's fake he wants them a given
course two weeks after their wild
nuptials - literally no one surprised
Tanna admitted she and Jake aren't
actually legally married and to
everybody that's calling it fake because
we rushed into it or because I don't do
things traditionally because I wanted to
not do it legally but any wedding I have
if I had three more weddings I really
didn't want to do it on paper because I
think that legally binding yourself to
someone takes away the love okay I'm all
for love but I am NOT putting my money
on these two going the distance of
course et will be right here to keep you
up to date on Janna the gift that keeps
on giving
until next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye
for now
[Music]